how can we practice how do we practice a
know what if we're people pleasers and
we don't we just don't want to hurt you
I am a people pleaser I want everyone to
like me to the point that i have google
alerts set up and if someone on a blog
or review says something about me or a
performance that is not favorable I'll
go there I'll leave a comment and say
you were absolutely right I agree with
you I made bad mistakes there and you
know I hope you'll give me another
chance in an effort to get that person
which they usually do to then say oh
well you know for sure i'm glad you
thanks for writing and I'll be looking
for you in the future like it's
pathological with actors that we have to
have everybody has to like us and our
relationship with everybody has to be
okay I don't know any actor who likes to
have someone they think does not like
them I have one wardrobe person in the
hundred projects I've done who doesn't
like me I hung the hanger the wrong way
it was early on and I didn't know the
way to hang the hanger but I was trying
to be nice and instead I made extra work
for her and I'm still looking for a
chance to work with her again to make
her like me is that sick so what's a
soph know and what's a hard note because
some people are really good at
hard-nosed and they enjoy being the
contrarian and they enjoy being the one
in control but how a soft know how you
better do soft nose in LA are you ain't
gonna work if all you can do is hard
nosed forget it because you insult
people a hard no is carrying your crazy
why would I work on your project I will
never ever work with you or anybody that
you know again because I've said that
and how many people will you tell that
but a soft know is I really really love
this project and i love the role and i
want to do it and I wish that I were
financially stable enough to be able to
pick and choose my roles because if I
did I'd be on your set today I'm just
not able to do it right now and I feel
really bad about it I'm embarrassed to
even mention it
to you but I hope you might find in your
heart to forgive me for not being able
to work with you that's an extreme salt
no I was beautiful but I mean it I
always mean it you know you never tell
somebody no you always say oh my gosh
you know I'm so sorry I wish I really
wish I could and I want to but I just
can't right now but in the future I
really want to work with you because and
this is another thing actors coming to
LA need to realize people love to be
stroked they love to be stroked look up
the ivd what have they done research
them on the web I really want to work
with you in future even though I'm
saying now because I like what you did
on ABCD then you've built a relationship
within the know that's the way to do it
I like that now your representation can
give a hard no and then you can say oh
my gosh you know are you gonna do I'm
sorry my manager my agent or such
hard-asses but i really love you keep
your personal relationship good is there
anything in this business that's real
hearing myself talk i'm wondering is
this entirely a business of illusion
possibly yeah yeah but i think what
you're saying is correct in terms of
like the the coldness and being able to
even on that red carpet because that
that little part is just such a
miniscule part and that's what everybody
sees and and they don't see where you
walk into rooms and you feel the vibe
and it's not as friendly or it's not you
know and it's not to be negative you
know we're trying to be more positive
with our film courage interviews but I
think people from other parts don't
realize that
it is toughen and I think it's good that
you're giving you a healthy dose of
reality and you're not sugar coating
coating it and you know follow that your
dreams and money hole fault you know
that that kind of thing I'm I think the
only reason to do this is because you
feel that you were born to do it and so
that's where you put up with all the
crap and that's why you think through
all the business strategy and that's
where you do at all is because it feeds
something inside of you to pretend to be
other people or to create stories where
other people pretend to be other people
I have no idea where that comes from but
i think it's an inborn vocation that's
the only kind of person that should be
an actor and then your satisfaction is
actually getting to do what you love for
a living if you do all this other stuff
so i answer my own question by saying
that's what's real the passion that's
within us that's what's real and you
have to keep that burning and keep it
alive even as you go through all of the
business and if you're able to sit in a
cubicle five days a week and then just
go to movies and live all that out on
the weekends then it's great but don't
come to Hollywood
you